tear gas and water cannons can't dampen
the anger in sri lanka
police fired both to stop protesters
from heading towards the president's
house
they had already marched to the
president's office
trade union members artists religious
leaders and ordinary sri lankans joined
the demonstration
the biggest victory for us so far is
awakening the public to make people
speak out about their problems take to
the streets and to push politicians to
provide answers to those problems we
will not stop till we win the struggle
the protest started as a grassroots
reaction to power cuts with small groups
of people gathering at street corners in
silent rebuke of a government they
accused of mismanagement and corruption
but a violent crackdown on demonstrators
who camped outside president gotaber
rajapaksa's private residence push
people to take a stand we need
rajapaksa free sri lanka corruption free
sri lanka so
lot of things to come so we the people
will know how they have run this country
and why we are suffering this these
economic problems those problems include
almost no foreign currency reserves
which means the government cannot afford
to buy food medicine fuel and cooking
gas
people now
waiting day and night in the queues
looking for their facilities
but still these
rulers would not
come forward to solve in this but still
they are struggling to maintain their
power
more sri lankans are struggling under
escalating costs inflation is 34 or 123
percent depending on who you believe
and for the thousands gathered here
their original demand of gota go home
remains unchanged benell fernandez al
jazeera colombo